homeschooling has become very popular in
recent years much much more popular than
in past years school choice has become
more popular people want to break out of
this monopoly of government education
and as that that is happening the
government is trying to take more and
more power so even if they can't expand
the percentage of kids that they're
getting they want to expand the time
line so for instance when I was you know
when my father was a kid you didn't have
to go to kindergarten that was kind of a
new thing and we're so he just went
straight to first grade then when I was
a kid you had kindergarten but I didn't
go to the like preschool or anything
like that and now kids go to preschool
at age 4 or age 3 I've even heard of
people sending their two-year-olds to
preschool right so you extend the amount
of time that the government gets with
you kids and that even if it's private
preschool that the the kind of liberal
apparatus gets with your kids then now
they want everybody to go to college
even if they're gonna go away into debt
even if they're going to get a worthless
degree that deprives them both of
education and job prospects they just
want to keep you in those instant that
that state liberal institution longer
obviously in kovat people are gonna have
to start homeschooling and harvard is
having none of it
the elite academic apparatus is trying
to shut down homeschooling you heard
from this woman Elizabeth Barthel it
she's a Harvard Law School professor she
came out and basically said she wants
homeschooling band now she's got another
article this was published in the
Harvard Gazette a warning on
homeschooling nationally renowned child
welfare expert Elizabeth Barth Allah you
know how great those experts are we've
been talking about them a lot on the
show in the last few weeks those experts
you can't question them so so I don't
know what it is that makes her an expert
but that the Harvard says she's an
expert so she is she wants to see a
radical transformation in home school
she argues that the lack of regulation
in the home schooling system poses a
threat to children in society so we got
to shut it down two points she makes on
homeschooling both of one is more
laughable than the next she says behind
the rapid growth of the homeschooling
movement is the growth in the
conservative evangelical movement
dun-dun-dun not those evangelicals not
conservatives conservative Christians
wanted the chance to bring their
children up with their values and belief
systems and so a homeschooling is a way
to escape
from the secular education in public
schools yeah well no it's not a way to
escape from secular education because
the secular education is all around us
in the culture in the government in the
law everywhere right but it's a way to
have an alternative so you're gonna get
bombarded with secular liberalism all
day long but maybe you can get a little
bit of an alternative in homeschool they
fought the battle with public school
systems to have their children exempted
from exposure to alternative values in
the schools and lost that part she gets
completely backwards the whole reason
for homeschooling is to show children an
alternative this apparatus of media and
legal advocacy and education and
Hollywood and everything together that
is the monolithic liberal secular
culture that you're being bombarded with
24/7 so going to church which they're
not allowing us to do right now and
they're exploiting kovat as a reason to
shut down churches and arrest pastors or
doing homeschooling which they don't
want to allow us to do some of the great
legal child welfare education experts
want to ban that sort of thing that
would be the alternative and yet they
don't want an alternative they don't
want any competition to their system to
their narrative they don't want you to
take the red pill so The Gazette asks
this professor bartholow could you
compare the homeschooling phenomenon in
the u.s. to other countries and here's
the part where you you can't even
believe that they're this unselfish
if we look at what goes on in other
countries the u.s. stands out as an
anomaly when other countries allow
homeschooling they regulate it much more
strictly they demand that parents show
they are qualified to teach and that
they turn in the curricula they plan to
use to the state so these other
countries they basically make
homeschooling just a facet of the state
so it really can't really provide an
authentically alternative possibility
toward the kind of shallow leftist
education that people are getting now
because
state's got to sign off on it and then
here's the money lot
they also mandate that the homeschooling
curriculum provides an education
equivalent to public school and includes
teaching about the fundamental values of
our society
some countries like Germany effectively
ban homeschooling altogether in the u.s.
there is essentially no effective
regulation so I'm a little bit of a
history buff you know and I got friends
in Germany I've quite a bit of respect
for some elements of German culture but
Germany's got a little bit of a
checkered past you know on history and
everything so whenever I see Germany did
it and that's why we should do it too I
just at Google you know I just want to
double check okay so I Google and I try
to figure out when did Germany
effectively ban homeschooling altogether
under what notoriously mustachioed
regime with that screaming guy did they
ban homeschooling and yeah you guessed
it it would be it would be the Nazis so
so the left
think about perverse this is when a guy
like Elon Musk says hey I'm taking the
red pill I'm questioning the official
narrative I'm thinking of alternative
ways to envision society and education
in life when you say that they call you
a Nazi but when you explicitly endorse
Nazi policies and and admit that their
Nazi policies you say I want to do what
the Germans did in the 30s but then
you're not a Nazi then you're a good
wonderful liberal open-minded person and
and they won't get called out for it
because because the education is so weak
even in places like Harvard which was
once one of the top universities in the
country
[Music]
[Music]